C’est une nouvelle qui a fait l’effet
d’une petite bombe
dans le monde de la science.
A grand renfort de communication,
Google vient d’annoncer
que sa filiale DeepMind venait
tout simplement de résoudre
un des problèmes les plus importants
de la biologie:
le repliement des protéines.
Il s’agit d’un problème qui résistait
aux biologistes depuis plus de 50 ans,
et que DeepMind a résolu grâce à ses
algorithmes d’intelligence artificielle.
Nous promettant au passage
que cela permettra de trouver
des médicaments contre
tout un tas de maladies,
aider à la lutte contre
le changement climatique,
réussite aux examens, permis de conduire,
retour de l’être aimé, etc.
Est-ce qu’il s’agit d’un buzz savamment
orchestré par Google?
Est-ce que la nouvelle va se dégonfler
quand d’autres scientifiques se rendront
compte qu’il y a une faille?
Eh bien, si dire que le problème est
« résolu » est un peu exagéré,
il faut quand même reconnaitre
qu’il s’agit d’un exploit incroyable,
que pas grand monde n’avait vu venir,
et qui va effectivement avoir un impact
énorme sur ce champ de la biologie.
[jingle]
Pour commencer, vous savez que le terme
de « protéine » a déjà un sens
dans le langage de tous les jours:
ce qu’on appelle couramment « les protéines »,
ce sont des nutriments, qu’on trouve
dans la viande, le poisson, les œufs, etc.
Mais en biologie, les protéines,
ce sont plus spécifiquement
une classe de très grosses molécules
qui s’occupent d’à peu près tout
dans un organisme vivant:
elles font bouger les muscles,
elles contrôlent le métabolisme,
elles servent de récepteurs, de transporteurs,
d’anticorps, d’enzymes, etc.
Bref, ce sont les chevilles ouvrières
de toutes les fonctions d’un organisme vivant.
On les compare parfois à des sortes
de nanomachines moléculaires
qui œuvreraient dans nos cellules.
Pour pouvoir assurer toutes ces fonctions,
il existe un très grand nombre
de protéines différentes.
Rien que chez l’être humain, on en compte
des dizaines de milliers,
et sur l’ensemble du vivant, on en connait
à ce jour près de 200 millions.
Évidemment ces protéines sont largement
spécifiques à une espèce,
et donc quand on « mange des protéines »,
ça n’est pas pour les utiliser telles quelles.
Elles sont découpées en briques élémentaires
qui sont ensuite recyclées pour fabriquer
nos propres protéines.
Ce qui permet cela, c’est le fait que toutes
les protéines du monde vivant
sont fabriquées à partir d’une liste
très restreinte de briques:
les acides aminés.
Le vivant utilise 21 types différents
d’acides aminés,
qui permettent de fabriquer
toutes les protéines.
Les acides aminés, ce sont des molécules
élémentaires
qui obéissent à un schéma bien précis:
Un atome de carbone, qu’on représente
au centre, qui possède 4 liaisons.
Et auquel sont attaché d’un côté
un simple atome d’hydrogène,
sur un autre, un groupe NH2, dit « amine »,
et de l’autre côté un groupe COOH
dit « acide ».
D’où le nom « acide aminé ».
Sur la dernière liaison, on peut attacher
un peu ce qu’on veut.
C’est ce qu’on appelle un radical.
Les 21 acides aminés du vivant
ont chacun un radical différent.
Ici vous en voyez une liste avec leur nom,
leur formule,
et surtout une lettre unique qu’on utilise
pour les désigner, c’est plus pratique.
Pour combiner les acides aminés
et créer des protéines, c’est facile:
ils sont simplement liés les uns aux autres
pour former une chaine.
Une protéine c’est juste une longue chaine
d’acides aminés,
et donc pour la décrire, il suffit de donner
la séquence de ces acides aminés.
Voici par exemple une séquence qui décrit
une protéine qu’on trouve dans le Sars-Cov2,
vous savez le coronavirus
responsable du Covid 19.
Cette protéine est assez petite, seulement
111 acides aminés.
Ce qui fait quand même pas loin
de 2000 atomes au total.
De façon générale, quand une cellule
de votre organisme
doit fabriquer une protéine,
il lui faut connaitre le plan de montage,
c’est-à-dire quels acides aminés enchainer,
et dans quel ordre.
Et cette information lui est justement
fournit par l’ADN.
Pour simplifier, un gène représente
la liste des acides aminés
qu’il faut enchainer pour fabriquer
ne protéine donnée,
même si en fait c’est plus subtil que ça.
Alors très bien, une protéine
c’est une longue chaine.
Il y a des tas de protéines qui diffèrent
par la séquence d’acide aminés
qui forment la chaine.
Et on en a plein dans le corps.
Mais comment elles fonctionnent?
Ce qui permet aux protéines d’agir,
de se comporter comme des nanomachines
moléculaires,
c’est qu’une fois fabriquées,
les chaines ne restent pas comme ça
comme un bout de ficelle tout mou.
Elles se replient sur elles-mêmes
pour adopter une forme bien précise.
Chaque protéine a sa forme attitrée,
et c’est ça qui lui donne sa fonction.
C’est le truc essentiel avec les protéines:
ce qui leur permet de faire leur job,
ça n’est pas tant leur composition
exacte que leur forme.
Elles sont comme des machines,
et donc la forme est essentielle.
C’est le cas par exemple des anticorps,
qui ont généralement une structure
en forme de Y
qui leur permet de s’accrocher
aux agents pathogènes
afin de déclencher une réaction immunitaire.
Il y a aussi beaucoup de protéines
qui servent de récepteurs
et qui fonctionnent comme une serrure
qui attend sa clé.
La protéine s’active quand une molécule
de forme complémentaire vient se lier à elle.
C’est d’ailleurs ce mécanisme
qu’il y a derrière le principe
de beaucoup de médicaments,
et aussi de drogues.
L’importance de la forme des protéines
est telle qu’un certain nombre de maladies
sont dues au fait que certaines protéines
n’adoptent pas la bonne configuration.
On pense que c’est notamment le cas
pour des formes de phénylcétonurie,
ou des maladies neurodégénératives comme
les maladies d’Alzheimer ou de Parkinson.
Puisqu’on parle de la forme des protéines,
voyons un peu à quoi ça ressemble.
Ici j’ai chargé une représentation de
la protéine
dont j’ai déjà parlé, qu’on trouve
dans le Sars-Cov2.
J’ai pris celle-ci parce qu’elle est
suffisamment petite.
Ici c’est la représentation avec
tous les atomes,
donc on y voit pas très clair.
On va choisir une représentation alternative,
on va juste tracer la chaine
des acides aminés,
on va afficher la lettre et la position
correspondant à chaque acide aminé,
et on va lui donner une coloration
progressive permettant d’y voir clair.
En bleu c’est le début de la chaine,
et ça va jusqu’à l’orange
à la fin de la chaine.
Voilà, on peut mieux visualiser la forme
en 3D de cette protéine,
et c’est cette forme qui va lui permettre
de jouer son rôle, de remplir sa fonction.
Pour comprendre le fonctionnement
d’une protéine comme celle-ci,
et éventuellement la manière dont
on pourrait interférer avec
pour des raisons thérapeutiques, il faut
connaitre parfaitement sa forme.
Le problème c’est que trouver la forme
d’une protéine en général,
c’est franchement compliqué.
Connaitre la séquence des acides aminés,
ça c’est plutôt facile.
Il suffit d’aller lire les bons endroits
d’ADN ou d’ARN,
ce qu’on sait faire quand on fait
du séquençage de génome,
et ça pour n’importe quelle espèce vivante.
La base de données UniProt recense comme ça
les séquences de 200 millions
de protéines différentes,
et le compte augmente d’environ
30 millions chaque année.
Mais sur ces 200 millions, il n’y en a
que 170 000 dont on connaisse la forme.
Même pas un millième.
Et oui le problème, c’est que pour avoir
la forme d’une protéine,
on ne peut pas juste la mettre sous
un microscope et regarder, ça ne marche pas.
Pour déterminer sa forme, il faut utiliser
des techniques de mesure
comme la cristallographie aux rayons X.
C’est assez compliqué comme méthode.
Il faut avoir une quantité suffisante
de la protéine en question,
qu’on doit isoler et purifier.
Ensuite on doit la cristalliser,
ce qui peut demander
de tester une grande quantité
de conditions expérimentales.
Si ça marche, on passe ensuite les cristaux
aux rayons X
et on obtient ce qu’on appelle une figure
de diffraction.
Et après un traitement mathématique,
on peut si ça fonctionne bien
en déduire la forme assez précise
de la protéine.
Cette technique, c’est une évolution
de celle utilisée
par la biochimiste Rosalind Franklin
pour obtenir dans les années 50
cette image très connue,
qui a permis entre autres à Watson et Crick
de proposer leur modèle de
la double hélice pour l’ADN.
Aujourd’hui la technique s’est beaucoup
perfectionnée,
et elle permet d’obtenir
une représentation précise
de la forme d’une protéine
à environ 1 angström près,
un angström c’est 0.1nm,
c’est à peu près la taille d’un atome.
Le problème de cette méthode,
c’est que c’est long,
coûteux, et ça ne marche même pas toujours.
Certaines protéines comme celles qu’on trouve
dans les membranes
sont particulièrement difficiles
à cristalliser.
Il existe d’autres techniques comme la RMN
ou la cryo-microscopie électronique,
mais dans l’ensemble
ça reste difficile et long.
L’idéal, ce serait de pouvoir deviner
la forme d’une protéine
sans avoir à faire ces expériences coûteuses.
Et sur le papier ça devrait être faisable:
vu qu’une protéine donnée adopte toujours
la même forme,
on doit pouvoir prédire cette forme
à partir de sa composition,
c’est à dire de la liste des acides aminés.
Pour voir ça, il faut comprendre le mécanisme
qui fait qu’une protéine acquiert
une certaine forme.
Quand elle est synthétisée dans une cellule,
comme un collier de perle,
elle n’a pas de configuration particulière.
Et c’est grâce aux interactions
entre les acides aminés
qu’elle finit par acquérir sa forme.
Certains acides aminés sont chargés,
positivement ou négativement,
et vont s’attirer ou se repousser.
Deux atomes de soufre de cystéine peuvent
se lier entre eux.
Certains radicaux sont aussi hydrophobes
et vont plutôt se regrouper à l’intérieur
de la protéine.
Il y a aussi ce qu’on appelle
les liaisons hydrogène,
qui vont faire qu’entre deux acides aminés
un peu éloignés,
il peut s’opérer un rapprochement
entre le H de l’amine et le O de l’acide.
Et ça donne lieu à des structures
particulières
qu’on retrouve très souvent
dans les protéines.
La première c’est une forme de tire bouchon
comme on en voit ici:
ça se produit quand chaque acide aminé
se lie avec celui
qui est généralement 4 positions
plus loin dans la chaine.
Regardez on retrouve plusieurs
de ces configurations,
on appelle ça des hélices alpha.
L’autre structure typique, c’est quand
la chaine se replie sur elle-même
pour que deux segments
viennent en contact l’un sur l’autre.
On appelle ça les feuillets béta.
Et ces structures sont tellement courantes
qu’on a imaginé
une petite représentation symbolique
pour bien les visualiser
quand on représente des protéines.
Une forme de tire-bouchon
pour l’hélice alpha,
et une flèche plate pour le feuillet béta.
Chaque fois que vous verrez
des images de protéines,
vous retrouverez ces deux structures
un peu partout.
Mais le problème c’est qu’on ne sait pas
forcément deviner à l'avance
où elles vont se produire,
et en plus il y a plein d’autres déformations
qui existent un peu partout,
et qui contribuent à donner à la protéine
sa forme globale.
On ne connaît donc pas a priori la forme,
mais ce qu’on sait,
c’est le principe physique qui gouverne ça.
C’est le fait que les interactions
entre les acides aminés
permettent en fait de minimiser
l’énergie de la molécule.
Un principe général en physique,
c’est qu’un système cherche
toujours à minimiser son énergie.
C’est ce qui fait qu’une boule va rouler
au fond d’une vallée,
c’est là que son énergie potentielle
sera la plus faible.
Avec les interactions entre atomes
d’une molécule, c’est pareil.
En se déformant une protéine fait baisser
son énergie,
et elle se stabilisera dans son état
d’énergie le plus faible.
Le souci c’est qu’on ne comprend pas
comment ça se produit exactement.
Le biochimiste Levinthal a calculé un jour
que pour une protéine typique,
il existe quelque chose comme 10 puissance 143
configurations différentes.
Donc il est évidemment hors de question
d’essayer des formes au hasard
jusqu’à espérer tomber sur la bonne.
Le problème du repliement des protéines,
c’est donc pour les biochimistes
d’arriver, juste à partir de la séquence
des acides aminées d’une protéine,
à anticiper parmi la myriade de possibilités,
quelle est la forme qu’elle va adopter,
celle qui lui permet de minimiser son énergie.
Ce problème du repliement des protéines,
il a été évoqué pour la première fois
sous cette forme en 1972 par le prix Nobel
Christian Anfinsen,
et c’est ce qui fait dire aujourd’hui
qu’il s’agit d’un problème vieux
d’une cinquantaine d’années.
Évidemment depuis tout ce temps,
différentes équipes ont essayé
de s’y attaquer,
en ayant recours
à des simulations informatiques
permettant de calculer et d’optimiser
la forme des protéines.
C’est d’ailleurs dans cette optique qu’IBM
avait lancé dans les années 2000
le super ordinateur Blue Gene,
qui a été pendant quelques années
l’ordinateur le plus puissant du monde.
Du côté des algorithmes utilisés, la méthode
la plus connue est sans doutes
celle appelée "Rosetta", qui a été initiée
en 1998 par le biochimiste David Baker.
Elle connu plusieurs succès dans les années
2000, et quelques développements fameux.
Comme le projet Rosetta@Home, qui permet
à chacun de mettre
la puissance de son ordinateur à disposition
pour les calculs,
ou encore le jeu video FoldIt,
dont le principe est de faire s’affronter
des joueurs à un jeu de repliement
de protéines.
Pour pouvoir comparer de façon objective
l’efficacité des différentes méthodes
proposées partout dans le monde,
le biologiste John Moult a proposé
d’organiser une sorte de compétition
opposant les différents algorithmes:
la compétition CASP.
Cette compétition a lieu tous les deux ans
depuis 1994,
et se déroule selon un protocole bien précis.
Un comité d’organisation choisit
des protéines
dont on ne connait que la séquence
d’acides aminés.
D’un côté des expérimentateurs
travaillent à déterminer la véritable
structure de la protéine,
le plus souvent avec des rayons X,
et de l’autre chaque équipe qui prend part
au concours s’efforce avec ses algorithmes
de deviner à l’avance cette forme.
Et à la fin on regarde qui a été le plus
proche possible de la véritable forme.
Dans le domaine du repliement des protéines,
il s’agit en quelque sorte de l’équivalent
des jeux olympiques.
A chaque édition, plus d’une centaine
d’équipes participent
et ce sont plusieurs dizaines de protéines
qui sont utilisées pour les départager.
Pour pouvoir classer les différentes méthodes,
il faut un critère numérique,
un score qui permette de les comparer.
Ce qui est utilisé, c’est une quantité
appelée GDT:
en gros on prend une prédiction
pour la forme d’une protéine,
on la compare avec la vraie forme déterminée
par les expérimentateurs,
et on compte quel pourcentage des acides
aminés sont bien positionnés.
Voici un exemple, ici vous voyez en bleu
la prédiction et en vert la vraie structure.
L’accord est excellent
et le GDT est très élevé.
Mais dans d’autres cas, la prédiction
se plante et c’est beaucoup moins bon.
Il faut savoir aussi que dans la compétition,
toutes les protéines ne sont pas
de la même difficulté.
Certaines ont en effet des séquences
qui ressemblent suffisamment
à des protéines déjà connues,
on dispose alors d’une base
pour essayer de deviner leur forme.
Mais pour les plus difficiles, la catégorie
qu’on appelle FM pour Free Modelling,
ce sont des protéines très différentes
de tout ce qu’on connaissait jusqu’ici,
et pour lesquelles on ne peut partir de rien.
C’est un peu l’épreuve reine.
Alors à quoi ressemblent les résultats
des compétitions CASP?
Le graphique que vous voyez ici représente
le score médian
de la meilleure équipe pour chacune
des compétitions CASP depuis 2006,
dans la catégorie Free Modelling,
la plus exigeante.
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
le GDT de la meilleure équipe
oscille chaque année entre 30 et 40.
Donc les prédictions n’ont globalement
jamais été très bonnes.
Mais en 2018, il s’est passé un truc.
Une équipe a fait soudainement
une percée remarquable,
et a atteint un GDT de 60, dominant
très nettement toutes les autres.
Et en 2020, cette même équipe a
à nouveau explosé le plafond,
en atteignant un GDT de 87.
Cette équipe, vous l’avez deviné,
c’est bien sûr celle de DeepMind,
qui participait pour la première fois
en 2018
avec son algorithme AlphaFold,
et qui vient de récidiver avec AlphaFold2.
En deux participations,
ils semblent avoir tué la compétition.
DeepMind, il s’agit d’une start up
londonienne
fondée par le neuroscientifique
Demis Hassabis
et rachetée ensuite par Google.
J’ai déjà eu l’occasion d’en parler,
car ce sont eux
qui ont conçu ces algorithmes capables
d’apprendre à jouer à des jeux vidéo,
ou de battre les meilleurs joueurs
du monde au Go.
Déjà un exploit que les spécialistes
n’imaginaient pas arriver de si tôt.
Leurs méthodes se basent principalement
sur la technologie du deep learning,
et pour ceux qui ne connaitraient pas encore,
je vous renvoie à mon épisode
dédié sur le sujet.
DeepMind est donc entré dans
la compétition CASP en 2018,
avec une approche, à l'époque, originale:
l’algorithme AlphaFold,
qui a permis une percée remarquable.
A tel point que pour la compétition 2020,
près de la moitié des groupes avaient
d’une façon ou d’une autre
incorporé des algorithmes de deep learning.
Il faut dire que DeepMind avait eu
la bonne idée
de publier une partie de son code
en OpenSource,
ce qui est toujours bon
pour stimuler la recherche.
En 2020, ils sont arrivés avec
un nouvel algorithme, baptisé AlphaFold2.
On ne sait pas encore grand chose
à ce jour de cet algorithme,
car ils n’ont pas encore publié
sur le sujet.
En revanche ce qu’on connait déjà,
c’est sa performance
à la compétition CASP 2020.
Sur l’ensemble de la compétition,
toutes catégories confondues,
le score GDT médian d’AlphaFold est de 92.4.
C’est une médiane, ça veut dire
que sur certaines molécules
ça peut être significativement
moins bien que ça,
mais sur d’autres c’est encore mieux.
En moyenne, leur erreur de distance
sur le placement des acides aminés
est de 1.6 angström, à peine plus que
la taille d’un atome.
On est donc dans l’ordre de grandeur
de la précision des mesures expérimentales.
Ce que les spécialistes ont estimé,
c’est que pour considérer
le problème du repliement des protéines
comme "résolu",
il fallait un GDT d’au moins 90.
Au-delà de 90, on est aussi précis
qu’une cristallographie aux rayons X.
Eh bien voilà on semble y être.
Pour vous donner une idée de l’impact
de l’exploit réalisé par DeepMind,
voici une histoire racontée par
Andrei Lupas du Max Planck Institute,
un des arbitres de la compétition CASP.
Dans un article publié dans Science,
il explique que les résultats d’AlphaFold 2
étaient tellement bons,
que les organisateurs se sont dits
qu’ils avaient peut-être triché.
Lupas leur a donc envoyé la séquence
d’une protéine particulièrement difficile,
sur laquelle son laboratoire bloquait
depuis 10 ans,
malgré toutes leurs expériences.
Une demi-heure plus tard, il avait la réponse,
et ça collait parfaitement.
Même si on ne connait pas tous les détails
de comment fonctionne AlphaFold 2,
je voudrais vous donner quelques éléments,
basés sur ce qui a été déjà révélé,
et ce qu’on sait de sa première version,
AlphaFold 1.
Dans un monde idéal, on s’imaginerait
qu’un bon algorithme de deep learning
serait capable de faire le job
tout seul comme un grand.
On prend les 170 000 protéines dont
on connait la structure,
on donne d’un côté la séquence
des acides aminés
et de l’autre la forme, et on laisse
l’algorithme apprendre tout seul.
Alors ça non, ça ne suffit pas,
ce serait trop beau, il faut ruser.
AlphaFold découpe le problème
en deux étapes.
La première essaye de fabriquer
ce qu’on appelle une matrice de distance,
et la seconde tente de reconstituer la forme
de la protéine à partir de cette matrice.
Alors qu’est-ce que ça veut dire
cette histoire?
Imaginez que je vous dise de placer 5 points
sur une feuille de papier.
Je ne vous dit pas exactement où les placer,
mais pour chaque paire de point,
je vous donne une distance approximative,
sous la forme d’un tableau.
C’est ça qu’on appelle
une matrice de distance.
À partir de la matrice, vous pouvez essayer
de reconstituer approximativement
comment se positionnent les 5 points
les uns par rapport aux autres.
L’idée d’AlphaFold, c’est de faire ça
pour les acides aminés d’une protéine,
et en 3D cette fois.
La première partie de l’algorithme essaye
de fabriquer une matrice de distance
à partir de la séquence,
et la deuxième partie
de produire une forme complète
à partir de la matrice.
Concernant cette deuxième partie,
il existe des méthodes pour faire ça,
notamment en calculant
l’énergie de la molécule
et en essayant de la minimiser
par des petites variations.
Ce qu’on appelle techniquement
de la "descente de gradient".
Maintenant comment marche la première
partie de l’algorithme,
comment on obtient une telle matrice
de distance?
Comme je vous le disais,
on ne peut pas juste donner en entrée
la séquence des acides aminés
et laisser un algorithme de deep learning
se débrouiller, c’est trop dur.
Alors la stratégie de DeepMind
c’est d’enrichir au maximum l’entrée
avec des données physicochimiques
sur les relations entre acides aminés,
mais aussi des données issues de protéines
dont on connait déjà la forme.
A la fin, ce qu’on a en entrée,
c’est comme une sorte d’image
à partir de laquelle on va essayer
de reconstituer la matrice de distance.
Sauf qu’au lieu d’être un image en 3 canaux,
rouge vert bleu,
il faut imaginer que c’est une image
qui a des centaines de canaux,
plus de 400 dans la première
version d’AlphaFold.
Il y a aussi une idée assez intéressante
que plusieurs équipes utilisent,
qui consiste à rechercher des séquences
similaires dans les bases de données,
même si on ne connaît pas
les formes associées,
mais juste pour essayer de voir à partir
des variantes de séquences
quels sont les acides aminés qui jouent
les rôles le plus importants dans la structure
et pour orchestrer le tout, DeepMind
utilise ses algorithmes de DeepLearning
qui fonctionnent si bien sur les images,
afin que l’algorithme apprenne
à faire le lien entre ces données
et la matrice de distance d’une protéine.
Pour parler un peu de technique,
dans AlphaFold 1
il s’agissait de réseaux de convolution,
ceux qui ont connu leur heure de gloire
pour la reconnaissance d’image.
Dans AlphaFold 2, il s’agirait plutôt
de réseaux avec des mécanismes d’attention.
Il s’agit d’une idée assez récente
qui a été proposée en 2017
par des chercheurs de Google, dans un article
cité depuis plus de 15 000 fois.
Autant dire que c’est le truc à la mode,
ça a notamment été utilisé
dans les questions de langage,
comme l’algorithme GPT-3,
vous savez, celui qui écrit des histoires
tout seul.
Bon dans tous les cas, il va falloir
attendre la sortie de l’article scientifique
pour y voir clair sur la méthode,
et éventuellement la publication
en open source du code.
Alors faisons le point: est-ce qu’on tient
là vraiment une révolution?
La première chose qu’il faut dire,
c’est qu’il ne s’agit pas comme parfois
d’une annonce susceptible de se dégonfler.
On ne parle pas d’un article scientifique
qui pourrait être remis en question,
ou dans lequel il pourrait finalement
y avoir une erreur fatale.
On parle d’une compétition, et on peut
prendre le problème dans le sens qu’on veut.
Ils ont tout défoncé.
Maintenant est-ce que ça veut dire
que tout est résolu
et que grâce à ça on aura des nouveaux
médicaments à la pelle?
Pas vraiment tout de suite,
il faut reprendre les chiffres:
Le GDT médian dans la catégorie des protéines
les plus difficile, c’est 87.
C’est une médiane, et là dedans il y en a
qui sont à un GDT de 70, 60 voire moins.
Sur quelques protéines,
AlphaFold 2 s’est complètement planté.
Donc l’algorithme est pour l’instant
loin d’être infaillible,
et on ne peut pas lui faire
une confiance aveugle.
Une détermination expérimentale de la forme
restera le juge de paix.
Mais ce genre de travaux expérimentaux
va évidemment être facilité
grâce aux prédictions d’AlphaFold 2.
Ensuite même si on arrivait à prédire
parfaitement la forme,
tout ne serait pas gagné pour autant.
Il est très fréquent que dans les cellules
les protéines s’associent en complexes,
et que la forme d’une protéine
e soit pas forcément
celle qu’elle aurait si elle était toute seule.
Les protéines s’influencent les unes
les autres,
ça dépend de la température, du Ph
et on ne peut pas forcément
les étudier en isolation.
Et puis sur le plan plus fondamental,
même si on devient effectivement
capable de prédire la forme des protéines
grâce au DeepLearning,
ça n’est pas pour autant que l’on comprendra
comment elles acquièrent ces formes,
par quel mécanisme, pour quelles raisons.
Les algorithmes de DeepLearning
fonctionnent souvent comme
des boites noires,
et il restera beaucoup de choses
à comprendre.
Toutefois, il me semble qu’on a de bonnes
raisons d’être optimistes.
Si on prend le cas du Go, les algorithmes
proposés initialement par DeepMind
ont ensuite rapidement progressé.
Et on peut penser qu’il va se passer
la même chose avec AlphaFold.
Surtout s'ils partagent leur découverte
avec d’autres chercheurs.
Dans tous les cas, on ne peut qu’être bluffés
par ce qui s’est passé.
Quand le deep learning a révolutionné
la reconnaissance d’image ou le jeu de go,
c’était tout aussi spectaculaire,
mais sur des domaines
qui étaient des domaines traditionnels
de l’intelligence artificielle.
Là on a des chercheurs en IA qui,
peut-être pour la première fois,
ont débarqué avec leurs méthodes
dans une discipline assez différente,
et ils ont cassé la baraque.
Moi franchement ça m’épate.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui,
c’était dense, on a parlé de bio,
de physique, de chimie,
d’intelligence artificielle.
Si vous voulez des précisions
ou des commentaires
sur certaines simplifications
que j’ai du faire,
j’en parle dans le billet de blog
qui accompagne la vidéo.
Allez lire le billet de blog.
Les actualités de la chaine
ça se passe sur Facebook et Twitter,
et on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo.
A bientôt.